good afternoon folks this is the
subcommittee for House Bill 587
I'm called a meeting to order it uh one
105. the intent of Health Bill 587 was
to
create a donor registry for anatomic
gifts if you will basically if you are a
resident of New Hampshire that you could
designate your organs to go to at
preferred also resident of New Hampshire
that was the intent of the bill
what I also wanted to share with folks
here today is the fact that I have some
documents I emailed to you folks I also
have some documents that were
shared with us from the organization is
so
there are some handouts I res you
receive via email prior to this meeting
along with a handout that came from the
um
which organization
thank you
so the sense of time this bill was
introduced
to literally a few days ago there has
been progress made at the federal level
and the federal government now has
allowed or will be allowing CMS to open
up what was considered to be a monopoly
um on the
distribution or the assignment of organs
if you will to open it up to with a call
competitive marketing
so I wanted to talk to you folks here
today is given what's going on at the
federal level and the fact that we don't
know where the dust is going to settle
on the federal law with what CMS is
going to come out with for guidelines
what we should do with House Bill 587 we
have three options before us one
because again these are all
recommendations back to the full
committee we don't decide here we only
can make our recommendation back to our
full committee
we're option one we can have IPL as a
recommendation
option two ought to pass and option
internet study basically means that over
the summer time
we'll have another committee meeting
talking about House Bill 587
but what we should do going forward for
the next legislative body we can't bind
that body we can make a recommendation
to the body about whether we want future
legislation or not
so those are the three options we have
on the table before us today
you know what I'm study
ought to pass or in a study
so I'll open up my colleagues around the
table what your thoughts are as far as a
recommendation of those three
and why you'd want to support that
recommendation
all right
um
so before the federal law changed
I went and reviewed the testimony from
last winter
and the testimony was pretty
overwhelmingly opposed to this bill for
a variety of reasons one of which was I
mean a lot of our transplants if they
don't happen to Dartmouth they're going
to be in Boston and do we really want to
get Massachusetts all upset and have
them write a law which then makes it
harder for New Hampshire residents
potentially
um that was one of the arguments the the
um I think the other one was that there
were legal questions about whether this
would be lawful at all
and then with the change in the federal
law I'm going well we don't even know
what what's going to happen now and it
seems that um
that that at this point we should just
totally pause on this so
um either itl or interim study
um I'll come back to the inner study I
mean my my personal feeling would be itl
and then if the if down the road when
the federal laws settled people want to
bring something back they can
um
the other the question about interrupt
study is if we do that that would just
apply to next year
and so I wonder if the federal if if the
federal rules will even be
um out to to make an interim study
useful again in a study to be clear on
the terminology
in the study basically means that we
would go recommendation to our committee
then if it goes through the house that
way
then it'll be another committee that
would talk about what to do as next
steps and that would be whether to
bring forward legislation or not bring
forward legislation that's basically the
only thing that can be done at that
point in time to bring forward
legislation requires another
member legislative body in the
subsequent session or term to bring
forth that legislation we can't bring it
forth
um
my first inclination would be a
to recommend committee or to pass and
let the whole house debate it because
since we worked on this bill in the
spring
from testimonies it looked like
everything is fine but apparently you
know and some other
Federal systems that were managing uh
this organ procurement and distribution
had some major problems said this bill
can at least partially
address so I think
the data which we saw
this summer actually shows that
there is some
some actual problems that this bills
representative Regis
did you want to add any comments to this
conversation
I do understand that representative
McDonald will be here in about five
minutes so we can take a slight pause
until he gets here
um
so representative
blows up pelosia
how do you
say your last name again for me pull
okay president Pelosi recommendation is
to octopass
okay yes and representative Palmer your
is there anyone in the audience that
wants to address the committee
foreign
good afternoon my name is John
Fitzpatrick I'm Chief public affairs
officer at New England donor Services
New England donor Services is the organ
procurement organization designated by
the federal government to recover organs
and tissues in the six New England
states so as such we recover organs and
have and work with around 200 different
hospitals in New England
we understand the purpose from speaking
to the representative cambrells who
wrote the the legislation was his
concern that allocation changes in 2021
would negatively impact New Hampshire
patients and in an attempt to get in
front of that issue he wanted to keep
New Hampshire organs close to home our
view is when you look at the data that
the system of allocating organs based on
how long someone's been waiting how sick
they are and how close they are to the
donor is a significantly better way of
allocating organs than had been done
previously which were based not on a 250
mile concentric circle around the donor
but based on
um archaic lines drawn by bureaucrats in
Washington DC so our view is it
shouldn't be state by state it should be
patient by patient we should have a
patient-centric view of this how long
has the patient been waiting how sick is
the patient how close is the patient to
the donor those are the major factors
and not whether or not somebody is a
resident of this state or that state and
as you mentioned this would particularly
hurt New Hampshire patients who the
major majority of whom get transplanted
out of state there are kidney patients
who get transplanted out of state
including and then also every heart
liver and lung patient has to be
transplanted out of state because New
Hampshire because Dartmouth doesn't do
those transplants
to set up a system where it's state by
state and transplants say that take
place in Massachusetts go first to
Massachusetts residents would really
hurt the entire New England area and so
I think that our view would be the
current allocation system works for the
patients of New Hampshire and that the
data proves that and then secondarily
there is the issue of federal preemption
we are a federally designated organ
procurement organization Dartmouth is a
federally recognized transplant center
neither of us can do anything that is
off the list that is the federal
optn runs a computer algorithm that
tells us who the next patient is based
on things like time waiting and sickness
and body size we must abide by the list
and the transplant center has to abide
by the list so even if this did pass
that probably wouldn't be any changes in
New Hampshire because it would be
the thing that
would you mind taking a second to help
this committee understand the
subcommittee
the new federal law that was passed the
securing the U.S U.S organ procurement
and transportation Network act how is
that going to change things from your
point of view
there's been one organization called the
United Network for organ sharing that
has held the contract for a long time
the federal government is thinking that
it is very hard for other contractors to
apply for that contract because eunos
does so much at such a high level that
really nobody has the expertise to come
in and do exactly what they do what the
federal government is thinking is
cutting up the duties of Unos into say
five different contracts maybe a
transportation contract maybe a I.T
contract a policy and development
contract in that way maybe an IBM could
bid for just the I.T section of the
contract and allow say you knows to
continue with the policy uh contract so
it's that the most important thing
they're doing is uh breaking up the
contract and then number two putting
significantly more money into the system
I think eunos is operating off of seven
million dollars a year and this new
contractual system is going to be
spending upwards of 70 million so about
10 times more money is being put into
the system to run it at the national
level
um but so there are there are likely to
be as we come along uh some uh changes
in the way policy is developed and there
might be some policy changes I think the
big issue going forward now what you'll
see with allocation is the 250 mile
limit around the donor was is was a stop
Gap because when you think of it 250
miles is pretty arbitrary as well what
if there's someone really really sick at
251 miles so
um redoing the computer coding so it
puts more emphasis on how close you are
to the donor and how sick you are and
kind of leaving off the 250 mile
line
and so that will probably be developed
for kidneys probably in the next 18
members of the committee any additional
questions to the uh
the person doing the presentation right
now
thank you
I see a represented out in the audience
okay just want to be sure there's also
some members I think maybe the public
would you like to make any comments
representative McDonald any thoughts
about what you would like to see this
committee do
well it was first of all my apologies
for being late I was
detained but
um
I appreciate Mr chairman the emails that
have been sent out and have been making
their ways around
um and um if this was covered earlier I
apologize
um for not being here uh the email that
came out about legislation that
President Biden has signed how does that
impact this does it make it move or
that's the question before us okay all
right so that is not resolved yet
no I think the question that I see
before this subcommittee of our
committee is to make a recommendation
back to the full committee and my
understanding is we have three
recommendations that we could make one
IPL
to
OTP or three interim study
so I guess at this point in time
hopefully today we can come up with this
subcommittee with some recommendation
back to our full committee okay
sure
a question to chair uh is there another
option to
try to come
are we allowed to make some Amendment to
the bill
yes you are
so if you desire to bring
fourth in amendment when we get into
exactly session I will now refer to our
church here I believe at that point in
time in exactly the session you can
bring an amendment to the online bill
and then the committee will communicate
vote on the amendment and that Amendment
if it passes would then go into an auto
pass as a minute
and that's after this goes back to the
full HHS committee right we could
so actually it's four options because we
could do OTP
and to represent Yuri's
um comment we can also do an otpa a
recommendation to the full committee
that we could support the aligned Bill
my my thoughts on this is the fact that
we do have Federal preemption
and I think at this point in time not
knowing exactly what the federal
government's going to do and how they're
going to make
changes on the underlying
process if you will
um whether it's going to be multiple
contracts funneled through one agency it
was going to be multiple agencies I
don't really know that's been clear
I think the intent is to have one policy
National policy with different
contractors working under the same
policy but it's not clear in a federal
legislation that that is a mandate it
could be something which CMS is going to
work on and how they're going to work on
that I don't know I think at this point
in time given the unknown of what's
happening at the federal level and the
fact that we have Federal preemption
I'm leaning towards more to itl it
possibly to consider income study so
maybe by next summer we'll have more
indication from the federal guidelines
coming from CMS what their intent is but
right now I think to act on something at
Mr chairman
another another concern that's been
expressed is New Hampshire is a very
small state and if we start being
possessive of
uh who you know protecting our own
organs father States follow suit we
could we could be negatively impacted by
that if a library state were to follow
in that kind of policy that's been
uh take a question on
so
what are the benefits
of
um for the we will continue to work on
this bill or
if we continue to work on this bill can
it be introduced again in the next
session or
like if we kill it now like Israel like
um this is my take on it but I will
definitely defer to uh chairman McDonald
about the actual ins and outs of this if
it goes to interim study
then you'll have another bite at the
Apple with another group of our peers
I don't know if it comes from all of our
community members or become some people
within the house at that point in time
they would work on exactly what we're
doing now have earrings
discuss it and then next fall at the
election cycle bring forth future
legislation based upon the information
that they obtained during the interim
answer your question is you can't really
bring it forth in January but you could
have an opportunity during the summer
time
to have more discussion bring together
stakeholders and based upon the
conversation with the very stakeholders
is in subsequent year which would be in
2025 24. he could then bring forth
yeah if we were to itl and in the house
followed our recommendation in January
the bill can't be brought back in the
second year of the session the same bill
can't be brought back so it would have
to either be a Senate bill
um or is to the chairman Merchant's
point it would have to wait until 2025
in some form you know interim study
bills also basically the ultimate
decision is to either recommend and not
okay
where's the pelosa are you looking at
trying to bring something forward in the
subsequent legislative body versus next
legislative year
because if we're looking to do something
going forward instead of just doing itl
maybe the option would be an interim
study
and at that point in time pulled
together stakeholders with the various
stakeholder communities
and maybe you could be the chair
and at that point in time through those
discussions come up with a
recommendation back to the Full House
basically saying either future
legislation or no future legislation but
that may be if you're really interested
in trying to do something a better
um one thought I have is where the it
kind of It kind of comes down to a legal
question based on the federal law that
was just signed is that something the
legal council of the house could help
advise us on perhaps
that's a good point so how do we do that
either myself or you could approach him
attorney ciancie and see if he could run
to some kind of an opinion for this
subcommittee to either consider or or at
least that's uh you know I don't know if
you're planning to have another meeting
or not but uh well we have another
meeting or we just consider it you know
via email among the four of us and bring
a recommendation to the um the full HHS
committee based on attorney C ansi's
input that would be a consideration
perhaps
I don't know if you want me to do that
or if you want to do that or
um
if you would be so kind to your past
could be fine I think what I'm hearing
is that we're looking at preemption
based upon the underlying bill which is
587. where they would stand or we're
looking at something going forward and
saying based upon what's happening at
the federal level at the state level do
we have any wiggle room or is federal
preemption going to basically shut down
anything we want to do at the state
level right and you know I I can't speak
obviously for attorney ciancie he may
not feel comfortable rendering that kind
of judgment but we can you know I'd be
willing to ask him to
if you feel that's appropriate yes I do
a procedure question
um if
chairman McDonald is going to cast that
question it's does it
it's going to matter what we do to even
if we itl it that's sort of a then it
becomes a moot point
right
um so and if so I guess
so where I'm stuck is I I really would
be not willing to to vote
ought to pass for this but if voting
interim study gives gives us time to
find out whether it's legal or not then
um menu is a really good point
again what we do today today is I'll do
a recommendation back to the full
committee
so we could as a committee come up with
a recommendation
whatever that recommendation is
and then once we find out what's coming
on with a legal opinion bring that legal
support our initial recommendation or
change our recommendation at the time of
Mr perhaps
um
and that's my understanding the
subcommittee everything we do has to be
public
as it is today
perhaps we could have a a quick
subcommittee meeting even
the morning of the full you know the
full committee meeting uh which will be
probably late October or early November
the deadline for retained bills is
November 17th
perhaps we could have a quick one just
based on attorney C hansi's opinion and
you know make our official
recommendation at that time if that
sounds good
yeah
so at this point in time we're going to
not come up with a recommendation we're
gonna have a subsequent meeting before
our next full committee meeting which we
Legislative Assistant how do I fill out
this form that's before me because we're
not making really a recommendation we're
going to postpone things until then
so is there anything else we would like
to talk about today or should we make a
motion to adjourn
for that recommendation to meet prior to
the full committee meeting in October
November at the college share
that's fine I I know of no other
business to come before us unless the
other members have something
no
oh thank you well I joined the meeting
and we'll reconvene at the
prior to the next meeting at the college
share about 15-20 minutes before that so